dans 5 minutes vous pourrez pratiquer le
chikong de la femme dans l'atelier 1 le
chikong pratique chinoise pour retrouver
un équilibre visant l'épanouissement
individuel le bien-être ou l'entretien
de la santé à travers posture corporell
et exercices de respiration le chikong
permet de renforcer le corps et déélier
les membres en étant plus disponible à
soi-même on va déjà être beaucoup moins
stressé on va être plus posé et on va
pouvoir rentrer en lien avec les autres
l'enseignement du tchikong c'est
vraiment enseigner pour que les gens
deviennent autonomes et fassent tout un
tas de petites pratiques chez eux mais
que leur quotidien devienne un tchikong
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait rien que dans la
posture verticale ou assise ils vont
déjà être dans le chikong outre le
chchikong l'association organisatrice
proposait de découvrir diverses
techniques de relaxation et de bien-être
les cinquantinois ont ainsi pu échanger
autour de la sophrologie l'artthérapie
et et diverses techniques de massage
l'idée première c'était que de faire
profiter les personnes qui pouvaient pas
venir nous voir le soir donc on a dit
dans la journée les jeunes mamans qui
ont des enfants ne peuvent pas venir le
soir les personnes plus âgées ne veulent
pas sortir le soir donc proposer dans la
journée c'était plus facile pour elle en
ce moment on a besoin de se recentrer
sur soi et d'être bien pour être bien
avec les autres se recentrer sur soi et
être moins ESS à chacun de trouver la
formule qui marche de quoi repartir du
bon
pied